[Musique]
papier fait mais peut être
créer un petit clin d'oeil
c'est pas nécessaire de faire dix mille
tonnes
quant à pied bien fait fait mais il ya
une certaine allure qui est c'est
presque irrésistible
oui je fais je peux le papier moi je
m'appelle des buts de cours à 2 le
compagnie à 40 ans à peu près denise
lapointe je travaille à saint thomas et
je travaille avec des lettres carruthers
et probablement ça soit 91 92
et souvent c'est ce qu'ont fait donc la
couverture on a dû du tee shirt de
pompiers le cac +2 faudrait deux poutres
de quoi de paille de lin probablement
juste pour textures et l'intérieur de
ces déchets sont mélangés unis gèlent
joue le rôle de cours ne triste le lien
entre des employés et moi et c'est
indispensable
sans elle ça marche pas pierre cycle
énormément les gens connaissent pas rien
du tout sur l'industrie les pieds des
gens du ps a toujours été des gens qui
inventent des vidanges c'est comme les
insectes clanche des cadavres ou berlin
on cherche les chiffons principalement
autour montréal et on cherche les cotons
les les fibres pure et quand je cherche
le scrap pour pour mes besoins je
cherche le coton le lin pire le jt ou le
sisal pure sans aucune produit basé à
l'huile le smoke
le sourd s'élève le parti dans polyester
qu'ils font
tu vois c'est une sorte tracts et leur
secret
c est le film et c'est noir et les
senteurs différents j'aime les couleurs
parce qu'on utilise les couleurs dans le
papier on peut faire un tapis rouge avec
cela
la fumée blanche y'a pas de senteurs n'y
a pas de plastic trees fonde ce il ya un
qui est qui et par an mais les trois
hommes sont son canton pury ses
conclusions
nous ce qu'on aime faire c'est une
feuille de papier qui arme une à la vie
qui pourrait être utilisé et ça c'est là
que tu as l'impression que tu existes
[Musique]
tu devras extrêmement humble quand on
sait que tu peux faire la même chose
sans voix et la cinquième fois et cette
guerre extrêmement comprendre le fait
comme qu'elles ont on lève on les traite
par déchiquetage pour rendre le morceau
plus ou moins égales et puis on le
traite mécaniquement dans une pile
hollandaise carré acheter l'abatteur
c'était pour pouvoir battre ces chiffres
en mieux même
y'a pas de papiers sans zone on peut
battre la fibre comme en vous donc ça
nous permet de faire des trucs plus
battu - battus ou des mélanges peu
subtile la batteuse et sa machine à
papier c'est à son rêve
[Musique]
mais en papier il faut le côté là même
cherchent chacun des types de papier
à son propre exigence sans pronger
physiquement une certaine souplesse une
certaine force évidemment et il faut la
gratte ya pas une geste qui bouscule qui
secoue c'est pure élégance
[Musique]
le grand problème c'est les matériaux
hétéroclites c'est que bon tu peut
recycler un matériau qui peut mais quant
aux du spandex du coton de la laine
parce que même la laine on peut pas
faire de papier avec la lunella soir
c'est pas des films de celui de
l'obséder film complètement différente
quand tu peux avoir un matériau pure
simple ou même le recyclage de montréal
où on mélange le verre et le papier
aucune cape tiers canadienne qui utilise
du papier recyclé de montréal il est
plein de verre cassé donc on l'envoie
dans d'autres pays
donc ce n'est pas de dire et avec des
vidanges dans ton propre pays qu'il faut
que tu les exporte dans un problème tous
les artisans du quartier sont presque
disparu parce que oubliez pas qu avant
qu'on n'ouvre l'industrie textile à la
chaîne montréal faisait environ 70% des
vêtements canadiens fr montréal
donc ça tu es une strie complète est à
la mode mais ne t'es mieux acheter un
nouveau morceau de mode aux deux
semaines que d'avoir un vêtement qu'ils
soient portés pendant trois ans mais de
toute façon tu achète quelque chose
maintenant les moutons vont tomber de la
première semaine
la couture des coudes ma feuille de
papier cheikha va durer un minimum de
500 à 1000 ans parce que les chinois yan
ont trouvé quatre cents ans avant
jésus-christ ce qu'on fait nous ça dure
il est d'une urgence et il peut être le
plus important c'est difficile vidéo
c'est la poupée
on peut pas on peut pas trouver un
papier plus beau plus et cela fait la
fracture de l'ain c'est tellement un
simple ce lait on peut pas trouver
quelque chose plus simple qu'une feuille
blanche
[Musique]
si il s'est presque irrésistible de de
faire quelque chose de vrai
[Musique]